two
[Music]
all right hogs you better get some
running and squealing
come on out biggie
let's ride we are here
and we are ready
we've invested an additional
five billion dollars into the set this
week
we have uh added anti-air artillery to
[Music]
protect ourselves from air strikes and
drone strikes yeah of course
we had to
the the liberals they're coming they
hate the truth they hate truth seekers
and truth tellers
you know i'm gonna send a little truth
teller yeah in the form of anti-aircraft
uh
missiles i will never get vaccinated
never never that's why they i'll tell
you what boy
why straight conservative how else can i
offend you today
come on
they want it they want it so bad dude
they want it like
they just they want to make you upset so
bad they're just like please please get
mad it's like dude
you are cucked okay if you spend
all your [ __ ] time
making up merchandise
you know constantly complaining
constantly crying about the liberals you
are cuck to the liberals
okay the the by coastal elite are
winning
they're winning the culture
i don't know how
i guess i do like i don't know how
though for the most part liberals got
this uh
label of the triggered snowflakes
because i swear
i mean i guess there are some you got
this like classic social justice warrior
from yeah like 10 years ago that was
like humongous the girl who like freaked
out over the guy who's made the
humongous joke
but other than that it does seem to me
that like
the white conservatives are the most
triggerable
snowflakes
yeah they get just so upset about the
dumbest [ __ ] yeah vaccines for example
like i think yeah of course they're
ready to go to civil war over a vaccine
i mean it's unacceptable it's goddamn
unacceptable that they're vaccinating
people it's just communism and pecker is
mad
yeah he's a man
you know first of all our sponsors today
are stamps
and uh policy genius hassan how you been
by the way how's your week been what's
going on with you i'm pretty good you
know just uh working hard finally moved
into the new house the 700 million
dollar yeah seven garillion dollar
house
congratulations i'm glad you're in there
enjoying the fruits of your uh
labor there yeah it's uh it's it's been
good so far you know just trying to set
up a studio and whatnot uh and uh have
more guests on and things like that it's
not as good as this studio obviously
this is like the most expensive studio
in the country yeah this is like the gdp
of the whole yeah state
we're we're keeping the los angeles
economy afloat here yeah basically
single-handedly you're building a studio
in your new place
yeah i mean it's not like nice not like
a studio studio but just basically
it's a it's a larger room and conference
table i'm gonna be able to have like
guests on and then you know uh have
have better conversations because
currently whenever they come they just
like sit next to me and it's like
awkward they ate them ross thing
yeah i don't want to do that exactly
yeah
exactly
there's better ways to do it yeah
a window covered with like a bed sheet i
think he has a yeah it doesn't have like
a green screen or something as like his
he doesn't even have like a regular
green screen he better because his
background is like his unmade bed and a
window cover the bed sheet that's what
i'm saying and he doesn't even have like
regular he doesn't even have like a
regular uh curtain he just has like a
green screen no it's so nice oh it's
it's so good which is so bad yeah so um
god you've been in so many controversies
lately dude i know another one about the
brothel
oh my god that was insane yeah that was
that was absolutely psychotic where uh
i had i have a friend who's a stripper
and she dms me out of the blue and it's
like oh my god someone just walked into
the strip club while i'm working
in your chicken tendy merch right here i
have a video let's show it you want to
show the video okay oh i can't show the
video well here i can show the video you
can show it to the ass but i don't know
maybe we can blur it dan there's a
little bit of butt there it's just a
little ass
we'll make it work yeah we'll make it
work
yeah this could this is it mad sigma
energy
that's pretty funny
he's just loving life i mean that's a
[ __ ] great video right there buddy
yeah okay so what happened
so i i was like oh my god can i post
about this and you know i was like ask
ask the uh other stripper there and also
the fan if i can post about this and she
was like i asked
[ __ ] yeah like go forward he's like
really stoked he's like actually at him
too and i was like no he doesn't want
that smoke because i know like people
would be like people get like kind of
mad but i didn't want i didn't know how
mad people would get it you're right
so basically i consented
uh my friend consented but uh there's a
lot of swerfs on twitter who did not
consent they were like nah [ __ ] that
dude how dare you so wait what was the
anger about i don't understand um
there are a lot of people on the
internet that have uh really unique
perspectives that are really polarizing
i guess or they get like really
passionate about like particular
things and uh there's a lot of people
who just hate sex work like they they
think that all sex work is inherently
like
abusive it's all
it's all coercive
and that um and that like they'll adopt
the aesthetics of someone who actually
cares about the well-being of sex
workers but they but they're not they're
the the legislation that they advocate
for and the things that they say
routinely dehumanize sex workers
um
there are leftists who are who have
these opinions too yeah of course that's
weird because obviously the anti-sex
work take is usually a conservative take
of like it's immoral yeah i know there's
a lot of women that make a great living
from that and you can do it in a safe
environment yeah
and make a great living so and every
time like the government takes action
because they they want to combat they
the government always says they want to
combat sex trafficking right and sex
trafficking is horrifying it's it's yeah
it's awful it's a monstrous thing yeah
one of the worst things yeah except
every time they say they want to combat
sex trafficking like cess the foster for
example they end up literally taking
away resources from sex workers
that use certain resources like back
pages and whatnot
uh to to safely be able to do sex work
so
this is a major issue that's why sex
workers like routinely um fight back
against sort of stuff but they're so
marginalized and their voices are never
heard
so they pass a bill
they'll pass a bill to say we are going
to shut down for example like websites
that uh facilitate in like sex work if
you're like backpacking oh you mean like
a website that's like you can find an
escort online yeah
like for example and it's like
well there's like certain websites where
sex workers are able to
uh watching their theory about why they
want to shut down the world because
they're saying it's all it's all sex
trafficking it's just
there's there's no evidence there's a
sex trafficking boom there is there's i
mean sex trafficking does happen 100 but
that's like illegal separately you know
what i mean
but it seems like a web like a website
where you just find an escort would be a
good place to
potentially sex traffic well that's
precisely why you got to decriminalize
it so that the website can still operate
so that sex workers can still
communicate with one another about like
abusive clients and whatnot right
because this is like a huge issue
um
and
i mean that the ideal situation would be
something like in nevada where it's like
people can run a safe like place where
sex workers can work out of and then
like
the facility ensures their health and
that the patrons aren't freaks and
everything yeah exactly i mean uh that's
the advocacy here in america especially
revolves around decriminalization not
legalization full-blown
um because i think like
a lot of people are worried about like
the corporate exploitation element if
it's like full-blown legalized then it's
you know what i mean that's crazy to
think because then you have like actual
exploitation like hyper exploitation
um so coca-cola gets into the uh
exactly it's a escort game
but um
i mean the the things
the thing is like people were just like
super mad they there's obviously i have
a lot of haters who watch and i talk for
12 hours every day so you're gonna find
something in my archives that you can
like use against me sure and i talk
routinely about sex work rights and sex
workers in general and i have them on my
show and whatnot too so
um one of those instances i talked about
like all the way back in 2010 i think i
went to a brothel called artemis in
berlin i have this video too let me pull
it up so this is when people got really
mad right so they were like this piece
of [ __ ] uh
[ __ ]
you know he he went he's blowing his
millions dog i was in 2010 okay that was
[ __ ]
you know i'm gonna play the video so
people understand but i guess this was
the reason people got really mad
so this is a clip escort no shame
obviously sex workers real work i've had
sex with
not even escorts but also like straight
i i've gone to a brothel artemis in
berlin and had sex with
uh the workers there yes
oh i don't hide it i don't give a [ __ ]
why would i
yeah so you saying that
you did sex yeah and they're like this
is shameful
i don't know i'm so surprised by that
because i thought a whole big talking
point of of on the left was like sex
work is real work and all that kind of
no i mean there's of course there
there's a lot of different opinions
there i mean the left is never agreed on
anything ever so is it famous i guess
there's like even further left that i'm
not super aware of that kind of surprise
me sometimes when i hear about it
because i thought there was this
universal appreciation and need like you
understand sex work is just a necessity
of society it will never go away it will
always be here the best can the best
thing to do is to give them the best
conditions possible that's safe
and enables them to work and make a
living and do it on their terms which is
safe
for everybody that's like the only
that's the best and most humane thing to
do and that's what sex workers want yeah
like that's if you talk to active sex
workers like that's what they want
that's but
there are a lot of people like this that
will oftentimes always like bring up one
or two ex sex workers and there are
plenty of xx workers who are anti-sex
work and like talk about the abuse and
the industry and there is a lot of abuse
in that industry
par partially or not even partially like
almost directly a consequence of how uh
in the margins that that entire industry
is how it's like a shameful thing that
we need to like push to the side so that
allows really horrifying things to
happen right so instead of
uh
instead of decriminalizing and like
having an honest conversation about this
we like kind of uh push it we brush it
aside and then allow that ramp and abuse
to continue
so my argument is like i'm very open
about it but they were upset they said
that this was like unacceptable why that
guy alex is like he's like a [ __ ]
investigative journalist investigative
journalist who i've followed for like a
long time too he's like oh the guy who
tweeted it out yeah and and he didn't he
didn't oh this shows how he blows it
shows a lot about his [ __ ]
investigative reporting because he says
here the yeah it turns out that brothel
went to so he could have sex with work
quote workers was rated in 2016. they're
not workers they're not workers so by
the way they're all slaves like that's
what he makes it seem like so
he
clips this article right and i didn't
first of all it's in 2016. i don't
[ __ ] know what's going on in a
brothel
uh you know what i mean like
i'm supposed to know what could have
happened in the future because he's
saying that this is indicative of all
brothels all brothers or brothels are
like this and it's hyper specific to the
sex work industry and it's not like you
know um it's different than
the the purdue chicken factory that's
like hiring undocumented immigrants
because it's not the the entire argument
reduces to sex work is not real work
it's like just abusive and exploitative
and horrifying
and and it's all sex trafficked people
that are exploited and coerced right
that's the way that this guy
operates that's the way he thinks is
going on and there's plenty of examples
that you can point to to
prove that point right
um
so he puts this he posts this article
as though like i'm you know morally
culpable in this situation
but uh
then i i looked a little bit deeper into
it i was like that's kind of [ __ ] up i
mean not kind of [ __ ] that was super
[ __ ] up what is it first of all it was
for [ __ ] tax evasion yeah
and secondly
the there there was uh accusations that
like there might be sex trafficking
going on
and
but all of the people that uh were
appointed to in that situation
they were released and i believe the
brothel is now uh suing uh uh the city
of berlin for uh damages to on top of
that actually i actually have an excerpt
here it says
um the berlin authorities raided artemis
in a human trafficking investigation
some people on tw uh let's see here
basically what they do is i guess the
authorities do routine investigations
they drop in to see just to see if
there's any like human trafficking there
they didn't find any human trafficking
there yeah but actually
right because what they actually did
arrest people for as you said
was tax fraud and withholding social
security contributions so there was no
arrests
uh about human trafficking in fact and
it's routine and if and anyway it was
the people arrested were related to tax
fraud yeah i mean the the brothel is
still in operation it's not like you
know whatever
i mean what the [ __ ] why would he do
that well because he has an agenda a lot
of people on the internet have their own
particular agency why the left eating
their own like this i just don't
understand the dude well i mean i think
that he just well it
helps negative reporting until
franco covered it it was his his name
gets mentioned with philip franco his
man gets his name gets mentioned here
but if he cares
eating his [ __ ] la eat his own people
i just don't understand i don't think
they i don't think he sees it like that
he cares more about like his uh swerf uh
pov
than anything else like
and it was it was obvious
here's a real shot of him uh
uh drafting his tweet by hand yeah about
you uh
uh participating in human trafficking
and for those who don't know swerf means
sex work exclusionary radical feminist
it's the same as
you might have heard turf oh wow okay
trans exclusionary radical feminist
these are like you know terms i just i
don't get that i just don't get it it's
like how it's like i'm sorry but sex
work is just a natural fact of life so i
mean what are you gonna do about it like
so people want to do that like people
people enjoy that like
and and it's incredibly is incredibly
popular like a lot of people consume
porn for example
i think it's
i think it's like just incredibly
hypocritical of me to you know consume
porn and then not like advocate for the
interests of the people that make it you
know what i mean it's ridiculous like
why the [ __ ] would you not do that like
it's no different than how like
conservatives would be like yeah run
football man run and then like the
moment that they kneel for the national
anthem all of a sudden wait a minute
that's a real human being with real
problems um
in a lot of instances they're black and
you know uh uh have a higher likelihood
of being victim to police brutality and
they want to talk about it then you
remember like oh this is not just an
entertainer that's like dancing and
running for you know my desires
but instead of real human being with
like real issues and then there they get
very upset and it's kind of like that a
lot of people want to consume porn a lot
of people want to you know reap the
benefits of uh sex work but then they
don't actually want to
um when when it comes down to like
giving liberties and rights to the those
who are making this content or those who
are engaging in the active sex work then
they're like oh [ __ ] that
yeah all these that's i i i'm shocked
that there's people on the left that are
like anti
uh sex work that's just weird to me it's
legal in germany too yeah i know i've uh
yeah there's like a whole red like
district it's crazy there
from an american perspective it just
seems like hard to even imagine there's
like a whole district
in germany where
you walk into it and they have like open
street brothels women literally behind
glass
you can walk through the brothels
there's women trying to get you to come
goodness me shatner loves that trying to
get people to come into their room and
it's just like whoa i went there when i
was like 18. i didn't sleep with anyone
it was just uh
i was i was a baby i was a virgin i was
like just scared i was just walking
through there like what the [ __ ]
you know yeah crazy and and people look
at that and go well that's [ __ ] up
like you're objectifying yourself for
the male gaze or the male desire
um and uh there's this like weird
understanding
or meme on the internet that like
all sex work is exclusively created by
like exploited and abused women
for the interests of just like cisgender
heterosexual white dudes they're saying
and then they're not the [ __ ] case
there's a way their argument that it's
an empowering they're
owning their sexuality and making a
great living especially if they're doing
it in a safe uh way
exactly um yeah hamburg's red light
district that's where we you know it's
it's hard to shake off that conditioning
if you like grew up in the western world
that has like really puritanical points
of view especially in america against
like sex in general
then it's it's really hard to like
reprogram yourself to be like wait maybe
this isn't all that bad
um maybe this isn't that crazy
so you know
um that's why i advocate for the safety
and betterment of sex work and i said it
in the vice article too like
all work under capitalism is
exploitative it's done under coercive
conditions if you're singling out sex
work then you have more so a problem
with sex and not necessarily the work
itself
in chica what do you think about police
unions i hate police unions so so what's
the prob you love unions yeah hate
police unions
well the reason for why is because uh
police serve the interests of capital
rather than the interests of the working
class that's why in leftist like
leftists consider police to be clash
traders while they themselves are
technically of the working class i see
um they work against the working class
historically and also in contemporary
society so what i mean by that is
historically cops have always uh busted
through the picket line
helped scabs push through into the
factories
and have always engaged in
counter-revolutionary activity at the
best of the bosses and you see that
everywhere i mean you see that in like
the line three protests uh where
actual cops off-duty cops are being
hired by uh the the pipeline to go and
beat the [ __ ] out of like quite
literally
torture
some of the protesters there for example
so it's like
this is what they do so they and their
unions and that's the only reason why
they're unions despite being part of afl
cio uh their unions are probably some of
the most strongest and if not the
strongest
and that's because they serve the
purpose of capital rather than
interested in the working class so
what's the rule there for like good
union versus bad union
i mean there's like
i i don't even think about it like good
union bad union i just think that like
uh the only reason why they're able to
thrive in the way that they do
and have a a robust union is because
once again
they are the last line of defense
between the working class and those who
own capital the wealthy
and if they didn't exist then you know
if there was any sort of like uprising
or anything like that
which is very unlikely
in present day but if there's any sort
of like labor action for example labor
momentum
they bring in they bring in the strike
breakers you know
because the reason i ask is because we
were just joking about how like
they're getting they're ready to go to
civil war over the vaccine in chicago
the police uni like in chicago the mayor
issue one said all government employees
need to get vaccinated you see that all
over the place uh more places new york
la
lots of cities are doing that
and the federal government did that for
christ's sake um
and uh the chicago police force is
threatening to go on strike
uh which i think is illegal as a
as a
a vital public service uh yeah obviously
that's debatable but so what they end up
doing uh because they can't go on strike
because like otherwise you would have no
ems or you'd have no first responders
and whatnot and people would start dying
uh what they end up doing is what is
known as the blue flu
and uh we were talking about this before
the show but um
the blue flu actually happened in new
york uh in the past where
they don't full blown stop
working but
they call in sick and they basically
slow down their services
and when the blue flu historically
happened in new york city
um crime actually decreased
it's like
that is that is ironic actually it was a
work stoppage in i believe in 1971 when
around 20 000 new york city police
officers refused to report for regular
duty
and uh it was pure utopia for that uh 12
hours people were holding hands picking
flowers
as opposed to of course like when the
sanitation workers historically have uh
done work stoppages like
all hell breaks loose right it's just
trash piling up everywhere that's true
it becomes the city
gets even smellier than it normally is
the thing is like anyway it's just kind
of shocked me to hear the chicago
police union head talk or he's just he's
like a mag occultist i mean he's talking
about how
he was like the government has no right
to force us to do anything i'm like
you're a cop you force people to do [ __ ]
all day every day that's literally
that's literally your job yeah you are
enforcing the the government's uh the
state's monopoly i was like you do that
every [ __ ] day
so
and you know
and then the mayor tried to compromise
because she didn't want apparent uh uh
chica this is the union guy
love that yeah so he exactly so this guy
so before like this is like you if you
were polish
or irish
i could be uh
this is this is copy this is awesome
he has a great hairline as well which is
fantastic hairline you don't see that in
cops
like let me show off my hairline let's
do a hair yo pick your union boys
yeah it's uh which hairline you want
yeah he's he's
i mean he is a hairline king
i don't obviously i don't believe in
like uh race science or anything but
it's you know complete [ __ ] you
don't believe in race science yeah like
phrenology except for cop chronology
which is what i was gonna say i i
believe that like
you know their cops have like a thumb
like shape and they're right i'm like
you are the higher your level of power
is right right within the cop world
right and uh in the back of your neck
you've got like that
that yeah
yeah exactly and and that's your power
level as a cop i can spot a cop do you
think they become more thumb like as a
result of being a police officer or
their thumb like resemblance enables
them to rise the ranks yeah they're like
that's the good thing are they born a
thumb or do they become a thumb that's
what i'm saying i think they're born a
thumb they're born a thumb old jokes
aside yes obviously not they become
thumbs but you know
i just
it's just it's just too much of a
coincidence okay all i'm saying is if i
if i were to measure skull uh cop skulls
i would i would immediately be able to
be like this is a cop
right i'm saying right um but anyway i
put up the picture of the uh of the
union guy real fast again yeah so this
guy was defending the january this is a
[ __ ] cop he said the january 6
protesters
uh we're not doing anything illegal he
didn't see any reason to
arrest that it's like these guys killed
police
so this is the police officers support
this guy too so to me it's like proof
that
these guys are mostly mag occultists
and it makes and explains to me why
they're so happy to stomp on the face
arrest stereotype
uh minority groups
you know even in chicago is a very
progressive city but like the police
force is straight up [ __ ] mega cult q
anon borderline i mean so
this is something that a lot of people
miss for some weird reason because like
uh i don't know why they just like never
talk about cops or the police forces
like a political force
but um according to the police magazine
september 2016 survey 84 of the people
responded like cops that responded the
poll were planning to vote for donald
trump versus eight percent
for hillary clinton so yeah yeah so
these guys are i mean cops have
historically always been reactionary and
very openly are they uh you know
pro-trump um they they love it they love
you know they love donald trump donald
trump is doing everything they wanted
them to do you know
it is surprising because the biggest
police forces are in very progressive
cities
and um
but it it if it makes sense because like
that a job appeals to who i mean i don't
know they're like
these [ __ ]
they get they want to go
[ __ ] [ __ ] with minorities i don't
know does it just appeal to these people
like where did they come from why are
all these radical
conservatives joining the police force i
think the job shapes you for sure
because like that's your your tool right
that's your job and that's why people
say when people say a cab like all cops
are bad all cops passes whatever like
they don't mean like um you're just
automatically an evil person you just
can't be a good person while also being
a cop you'd be a good person otherwise i
don't know how many are i'm sure there
are some yeah i'm sure they're good cops
but
ultimately you can't be a good person
while in the act of being a cop because
you're enforcing all of the laws right
and a lot of those [ __ ] laws are
directly slanted against poor people
directly slanted against black and brown
people so if you're gonna do that then
you can't be a good person while in the
process of doing that even beyond the
laws i feel like in the police force
you are forced so frequently
to look the other way
and because there's so many shitty cops
doing shitty things doing violent acts
arresting people inappropriately
searching people inappropriately pulling
people
over inappropriately that you're you're
forced to look the other way probably on
a near daily basis so like even if
you're not
a bad cop they'll fire you
right they'll fire you they'll they'll
fight the only time you actually get
fired well i hear it all the time when
they when they file um
complaints on other officers
uh they get fired
yeah you can't eric shelvin was like
that guy should have been the guy who
killed george flight he should have been
fired [ __ ] yeah years before that
happened
but the reason why we uh turn the other
cheek or look the other way is not
directly because like the unions are
really powerful the police unions are
really powerful but more so because of
the tool that they are designed to be
and that tool has to be a brutal and
violent one because like oh god forbid
you know what i mean if they're not if
they're not enforcing then those
criminals can come into our
neighborhoods and oh no like that'll be
terrifying
um
so that's that's mainly the reason i
personally think it's kind of weird that
we have a very like we have a
essentially a para military group that
is literally above the law that is
completely unaccountable
okay that gets taxpayer dollars from
black and brown neighborhoods from poor
neighborhoods and then
directly takes that taxpayer dollar to
an auxiliary neighborhood that they live
in because like cops more often than not
you mentioned like they operate in urban
cities and like big cities and whatnot
but they're not actually from that
they usually have like little safe haven
towns like right at the precipice right
at the border of said city that town
gets all the amenities now because they
have more money uh but that town is
literally operating off of
the taxpayer dollars from the poor
communities and the poor neighborhoods
that are directly funding it so it's
this like very weird cycle of of um
taking
uh
taking money from the working poor and
then funding like little safe haven
communities that are reactionary as hell
at the precipice so
it's it's terrible all around like i
mean i don't i don't understand how you
can just look at
policing in this country and be like nah
it's working pretty good i agree and
well here you actually you have some
evolutionary evidence to support your
claim oh wow at one point we've evolved
past the human being into the
thumb
exactly thumbelina real race science
so there that's this is the hidden truth
liberals don't want you to see
straight up well anyway i didn't mean to
go into a tangent into a police and
unions and stuff i just thought i just
heard that that story about the chicago
police force today i was like man these
guys seem like [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
the the
nypd union uh boss was like straight
queuing on like straight queuing on i
mean uh
look they were
the insurrectionists were taking selfies
with cops inside of the capitol like
yeah yeah exactly you know they were
they they opened the doors for them
pretty much right like it's and then
they killed one of the cops
and they still simping for anyway
whatever i can't i it's a whole meme
hole the good news is uh well let's move
on to something light
for example michelle
fiori you know this lady oh yeah
he's my favorite he's running for uh
office and the
let's find out so this is the political
ads that we're starting to see in
america if you're not from here this is
going to trip you the [ __ ] out
but you know what's funny is i saw this
i was like that's an effective ad i feel
like that will work for the people she's
targeting here
[Applause]
i'm michelle fiore and i'm running for
governor
governor
i spent my whole life fighting the
establishment i was the first female
majority leader in nevada assembly and
one of the first electeds to endorse
donald j trump and you better believe i
was attacked for it
i believe it yep that's that's how you
get your bonafide post called me a
gun-toting calendar girl and politico
magazine said i was the lady trump and i
don't care
yeah
uh the the the washington post said i'm
unqualified to be governor and i don't
care the audio is terrible but the audio
fascinates me it fascinates wait is this
you didn't do the full video
what do you mean this is the full video
i just paused it oh you paused okay i
was i was worried this gets better
the audio fascinates me because it
sounds like she's in a studio but she's
in the desert and there's foil for
everything you can hear her like
crunching and then like the truck
uh squeaks and squeals on desert sand
like watch the beginning here like
[Music]
like is that a sound that you would hear
on sand i don't think so no no no they
they put everything in uh in post they
they made her i'm fascinated they made
her redo her audio too because he can't
they probably didn't get good audio so
you think it's all dubbed
in the studio 100 and it's the worst up
and i'm running
it's awesome it's the worst dub it is
absolutely the worst dub dude it's
amazing this is why subs over dubs boys
for governor
i spent my whole life fighting the
establishment i was the first female
majority leader in my whole life
to endorse donald j trump and you better
believe i was attacked for it
[Applause]
dude i'm sorry but like there's some
that fit is [ __ ] wild bro it's fit
it's just so wild i just i i don't know
what to say about it without like
getting canceled other than that it's
wild
yeah no i i i know i just wait wait till
she okay wait wait
there's a part of the video where it
like i'm just like it was hard for me to
not i mean she's she's got a leather
jacket and belt on
she's wearing a dress with a belt i mean
okay that's fashion i guess uh
but damn she's built like a [ __ ] uh
she's you know who she's built like alex
jones top heavy yeah she feel like a
tank
felt like a [ __ ] brick wall dude
washington post called me a gun-toting
calendar girl and politico magazine said
that i was the lady trump and i don't
care washington post said i am
completely unqualified and will ruin the
state i don't care for the for the
record like there is uh there are
reports that she is under fbi
investigation for campaign finance so
she is more like trump than she thought
i mean of course which one of these uh
fundraiser people is not shouldn't be
the washington post says i'm being
investigated by the fbi i don't care
we need outsiders fighters not the same
old boring moderate compromised blue
blazer politicians
let's start with a three-shot plan
[Music]
ban vaccine mandates ban critical race
theory
and stop voter fraud
that'll fix our great state those are
the three most important things
affecting our state right now in the in
the state of nevada yeah is voter fraud
vaccine mandates and critical race
theory it works though it works look
this is the funniest part never mind
education infrastructure healthcare or
any of those other why did you try to
holster this thing back
so she shoots the gun
and then she tries to put it back and
and then she forgets they just watch
people stop voter fraud just keep your
eyes on the joe biden administration is
coming after me
and i'm ready for the fight it's just
hard for her to pull it out and and put
it back in like and i suspect it's
well you know what this means to me is
they must have shot this so many [ __ ]
times yeah and then this was the best
take of the bunch but they must have
shot this so many times if this was the
best day an administration is coming
after me
michelle fiori
joe biden administrators are coming
after me so funny because like no are
you like no one knows you're you're just
like a fundraiser for the nevada
republican party uh and it's not the job
administration is the fbi that's coming
after you oh we've got more intel on her
well i just went to her campaign website
because i was curious uh you know what
it is on myspace website exactly that's
what i was going to say it's just and
look it's a bunch of photos and then
just her twitter feed there's no like
there's no page like policy or like or
what she
actually most important things affecting
our state is critical race theory
and
grass that's too long the the the
problem is look i i did a i did some
some canvassing in nevada for bernie
sanders uh back in the good old days
yeah when when things were looking
brighter yeah and i went to some of the
trailer parks there
and like most of the people are
completely tapped out of the political
process if you're living in a trailer
park and you're working like you're just
you're just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know
none of these people care or none of
these people care about me as an
individual right
but
when they do care
they were very republican now does that
mean that they deserve to be the trailer
of course not and that they like i want
to improve their material conditions
regardless
but
there are a lot of people that
would respond positively to this and be
like yeah that person does represent my
my initial reaction was like
this is gonna work like this this is
good [ __ ] for the target audience
yeah
they're like from a trip but that's the
irony from a trailer park in the middle
of the [ __ ] desert
they're like those are the three most
important things critical race theory
coved vaccines and uh
oh it's because what was the other one
right it's like all they consume is
[ __ ] fox news and like right wing
propaganda from sinclair broadcast
like controls all local news
so yeah they they are terrified of
vaccines they don't want the you know
actually
critical rights forcing the vaccines
you're in a trailer bro and you're
worried about critical race theory what
about like uh
healthcare infrastructure healthcare
better better workplace conditions for
you because like these guys are still
working and they're working on auction
conditions pensions benefits yeah
pay
raise child care the minimum wage like
pretty much every single thing that's in
the uh 3.5 trillion now yeah slated to
be 1.9 i'm more worried about critical
rates there being taught to my kids and
it sucks uh but uh i mean there's
definitely a problem within the
democratic party as well i don't think
like i mean
i don't know how they're [ __ ] it up
every year after year the democrats well
because they don't
they don't really care it's like you
have the real [ __ ] on your side people
want real [ __ ] but like somehow critical
race theories beating out yet again
like people they you hear them on and on
about critical race there and people are
[ __ ] like can't
but it's so big i don't care but that's
so obvious though that like the critical
race theory is just like a culture war
issue a wedge issue if you will that
they have cultivated that they've it's
not a real thing it's not a real problem
it's uh it's nothing really nothing it's
literally nothing yeah and um
and it goes away too like it's so
obvious antifa was a critical race
theory uh in the trump administration
like originally it was antifa then it
was like
mass mandates and it was critical race
theory and then it was the vax mandates
and it's always like
they just move on to the next thing and
totally forget about
um totally forget about everything else
what do you got here for us dan i was
just showing all the republicans this is
who's running for the wonderful
republican candidates running for
governor
so we've got michelle fiore who we just
met
uh joey gilbert from reno
that's his photo that he submitted
i guess it's just because that's his
wikipedia page because he's a
professional boxer so
and then who else we got here uh typical
white uh republican looking dude and a
cop so yeah there you go sheriff joe
lombardo yeah i'm something tells me
it's gonna be one of the two right guys
no i mean
so
nevada is is interesting i mean it's the
current governor is is a uh
is a democrat so yeah it's a blue flips
you know swing state
um so i
i don't know if uh if republicans are
you know easily going to control the
nevada gubernatorial race at all but
have you heard about critical race there
that is the most important thing
affected my life
yeah do you have kids sir no i don't
yeah or when they do you know what
actually is uh beneficial expanding the
child tax credit super popular provision
that republicans are blocking about the
like that's that's if you do have
children that is a million times more
important than [ __ ] critical race
theory is like getting child tax credits
like getting money back for or no my
child
feeling guilty like they did something
wrong that seems more important yeah
it's just um it's sad but that's what
happens
when
uh one side is not effectively
communicating the material needs that
people have
and the other side is hyper focusing on
really like flashy
uh propagandized talking points that are
tailor-made for consumption by this uh
audience they're better at it they're
better that's why that's why west
virginia uh in the uh in the in the
aftermath of the complete evisceration
of uh the coal mining industry and labor
union power there he is now plus 35 red
state when in fact like these are the
people that would benefit greatly
from
uh any sort of like left-leaning
leftist uh social distribution programs
um as they do by like actual ngos they
come in and do dental work for them you
know what i mean every now and then in a
[ __ ] stadium like it's disastrous
it's it's disgusting the way that we uh
we treat the working poor of this
country um i don't fault them entirely
for
having this perspective they're jaded
they uh how can you blame them at all i
mean they're just getting fed you know
it's like yeah and it's fun
all they do is just watch fox news
who at least like points the finger of
blame
and and directs redirects their anger in
the wrong place but at least redirects
their anger and says like you're right
to be angry and and uh works off of like
prior
uh uh the the prior ideas that have been
socially that we've been socially
conditioned into believing like white
supremacist values and whatnot
yeah
well i'm trying to be i'm i'm trying to
be more lighthearted today and i'm
failing disastrously
listen here i've got something
lighthearted for you all right let's
look at times conspiracy theorist rick
wiles claims that the covet 19 vaccine
contains an egg that hatches into a
synthetic parasite and grows inside your
body now this may sound insane to you
guys but this guy has done the research
we have the scientific findings true oh
okay this is good so she's built like a
kanye
one of these kanye dolls i feel like
this is attacking me i'm gonna be honest
with you
yeah you're kind of built like this as
well yeah be honest yeah i i an absolute
unit i think people would say no one no
one talks about you know how how
big men are oppressed in society we're
the real victims
yeah that's right
big men matter
big men lives matter yeah
i can't find clothes that fit me
nobody's talking about it it's messed up
it's not that bad for you is it you
can't find clothes that fit you
not fit correctly for my proportions you
know what i mean
but what are you going to do i mean i
was just kidding it was whatever come on
dude don't stop [ __ ] complaining bro
you probably you like you got tall guys
get it all bro like tall guy like do you
know how many girls are just like i want
a guy who's over six too that's it
all right so shut the [ __ ] up i do know
yeah yeah you you are right i just want
a guy who's six threes the perfect
height anyone under six foot though i
won't even even cause if you say i'm six
four so
see uh then they say i'm too tall
no one says that no one has said that
i'm not exactly i'm now officially lying
you're a [ __ ] you're the hog now boy
exactly the real victim
me i don't hear [ __ ] from tall guys
all right let's watch this pastor
yeah is a global coup d'etat
by can i get a little volume for the for
a boy over here he's a soft he's a he's
got a soft voice
this is a global coup d'etat
by
the most evil cabal of people on the
planet in the history of mankind
and if it is not stopped
in the very near future they will win
that's what's at stake control of the
world they're planting they're putting
eggs
in people's bodies
if you didn't see yesterday's true news
you need to watch it
it's an egg that hatches into a
synthetic parasite
and grows inside your body can you
believe that i it's just
like a sci-fi
it's not like a sci-fi movie and it's
happening in front of us this is a
global so what happened did this dude
like uh
you know smoke some of that k2 or
whatever some synthetic marijuana and
was like i'm watching alien like
yeah there's i have a whole son actually
can you guys drop the link here i i
yeah he's got a whole kind of pseudo
scientific research paper into
how the eggs hatch in the vaccine and
apparently it's something like in the
matrix i don't know if you remember this
but i think this is probably where he
got the idea
you know
where that bug goes in neo yeah his
belly button yeah he saw he he watched
that and was like this is real this is
what's going on
i feel like
but i love plagiarizing i love how it
goes can you believe that
can you believe that
it's like
no no but they can yeah the people that
are listening
this is like a site
it's like a
sci-fi dystopia
can you believe that he literally says
it's like science fiction it's like
fiction it's like something it's almost
like fiction yeah
because it is it is he he plagiarized
this like he he did not come up with
this on his own you know what i mean
yeah so but there's a there's a paper
for it you're saying yeah but i mean
there's just man the the amount of
crazies in this country is just
staggering i mean they are everywhere
and you can call in right now to true
news
with the donation to fight the parasites
in our blood
it's just always wild to me i mean i
guess like i i understand why like these
guys are popping off like the the guy
greg locke right yeah
um james fetzer exposing falsehoods and
revealing truths brother yeah when i dug
into it this is what seems to be um yeah
so they've this is the virus they've
captured uh
something like this is going to develop
inside you oh so this isn't it just
something like this what's the name of
the documentary
i believe this is this is the image that
they point to this is the
frog awesome here they says parasite
that may have been identified
as hydra vulgaris
which is darkened for the bar has been
seen in the covet vaccine pick credited
to the stu peterson show
and dr carrie madage
i love that they just like they'll
always find like one [ __ ] psychotic
doctor i doubt that kind of doctor do a
google search on that i i already looked
it's uh
i found her
she has a phd she's an osteopathic
internal medicine doctor
and stands for freedom truth great love
child of god
she's got a rumble page
okay oh
man and uh you know
but her instagram is just full of like
lions
throw it up elite global leaders
conference talk em out
like did can hassan put stuff up dan no
but i can say if you send it to me i'll
pull it up oh okay is there a way to
actually just as a side note is there a
way to get him access to this tv so we
can put stuff up too
that would be a technical challenge but
i feel like we could do it we can do
anything here on leftovers with this
trillion yeah i mean our budget's insane
yeah yeah so here here it is this is her
uh instagram
oh yeah the lion imagery trigger fall
let's keep an eye on her on the podcast
account let's keep an eye on her yeah
oh man they won the nobel prize
this is like the page when someone's
unwell mentally this is what their page
looks like 100
yeah it's just like wow
look i have given you authority over all
the power of the enemy and you can walk
among snakes and scorpions and crush
them nothing
will injure you luke
wait except that hydra
the hydra and the in the bible passage
it starts with look
i i that doesn't sound i couldn't say
luke 10
10 19 you can fact check it maybe maybe
it starts with luke but they changed his
look
no jesus they added the look
look
look folks
an amish to joe but i don't look folks
well there's a lot of versions of the
bible so
yeah they they got they got patch notes
up in this right bump in this [ __ ] yeah
so shout out to um
yeah saying that doctors have died or
something to like uh you know present
the truth to you or it's just like
it's just crazy madness it's like 98
or 96 doctors have gotten vaccinated and
and like oh like 99 98
yeah and it's like you're you're so
desperate to find like the two percent
of doctors is like yeah no this is fake
this is actually fake yeah and hyper
focus well they do the same thing with
global climate change they do the same
thing with every like wedge issue that
they're trying to propaganize
propagandize
and uh it's [ __ ] [ __ ] and they're
really good at it but i think it's just
like comes from you know these people
are bored they're looking for like uh
fun stuff and this is fun you know what
i mean this is like
yeah it's it's i'm living in the matrix
you know it's like it's like what a
child when i was a kid that's what i
would do in my child brain and i feel
like a lot of conservatives just like
straight up have
child brain where they are like
i do want to i i do live in the matrix
like i am the main hero
and i i'm the one who knows you know
what the real truth is about the vaccine
it's the called the main character
syndrome yeah exactly
anyway rest in peace to the gulp
colin powell uh this is my favorite
quote about colin powell from kurt
vonnegut he said
the last thing i ever wanted was to be
alive when the three most powerful
people on the whole planet would be
named bush dick and colin
i
i find that to be a little cringe but
hey that's just me you don't like that
quote no i think it's so like it's so
cheese dude but hey whatever what it's
such a great quote oh you were even
snickering yeah i know i'm i'm just
laughing because like it's uh
it's what bush dick and coleman yeah i i
mean are you gonna sit before me and
tell me that's not [ __ ] hilarious i i
i know i it's i don't know
i it it it reminds me of uh simpler
times like the anti-bush liberal era so
like at least i i feel a sense of
comfort from that when like liberals
were actually anti-war and not like bush
and colin
you know and not totally on board
well anyway uh colon rip to the goat are
we going to talk about the real story
here though yeah true like i don't
really care about colin powell i think
he is a horrible uh monster for the most
part i mean look if you worked with a
reagan administration that's already
like you're disqualified from ever being
covered uh gently in your passing
um
also on top of that he is and forever
hopefully will be remembered as the guy
who lied to the united nations that's
his legacy to go to uh you know iraq and
that's his legacy and he claims that
like oh he felt really bad about it
afterwards like oopsie it's like dude
you literally had every opportunity
throughout that administration
to at least try to right the wrongs that
were conducted
and you didn't do that and
once it was fashionable to do so only
then did you come out and you were like
oh man i felt really conflicted about
that
and these guys look
he died at the age of 84. he was
vaccinated he died because he had like
cancer as well he was like you know
really immunocompromised
but he died alongside his family and his
alongside his loved ones at the age of
84. yeah right
whereas
that is not a liberty or privilege
afforded to
hundreds of thousands of people in iraq
how many people died there like half a
million civilians yeah and conservative
estimates that [ __ ] ins exactly and
then also on top of that like that that
region is just like completely broken in
a state of disrepair as a consequence of
people like colin powell so well it's
really i find his story really sad and
tragic because
like
the whole reason that his testimony held
so much weight when he said there was
weapons of mass destruction because
everybody trusted him he was this
widely respected and trusted thing so
they used him
and unfortunately he was more than
willing to be used by them to as a means
to basically send off war to just kill
[ __ ] hundreds of thousands of people
in a conquest for american
companies to make money selling oil yeah
i mean he his his career started off in
the vietnam war and he was in charge of
like
investigating the my life massacre and
uh
you know
um
i i'm sorry but like
yeah he's just not a good guy so which
is why
i love this rip to the goat i love this
so donald trump
is never one to let down and that's why
i'm excited to see him back i can't wait
for his new social media i can't wait
for him to be running
he is uh from one goat to another i miss
him so much yeah
when i see post like this i miss him
this is him this show is gonna slap so
hard when he comes back yeah
um state we're basically just waiting
for trump's return i mean we're [ __ ]
anyway you might as well just enjoy it
at this yeah yeah yeah you know that's
the way i see it so here is a statement
from the president
wonderful to see colin powell who made
big mistakes on iraq and famously
so-called weapons of mass destruction be
treated in death so beautifully by the
fake news media
he's actually right he's 100 even on
like cnn and all these like liberal news
medias they're like fawning over him
which is really yeah they covered him as
a as a guy who is known for an oopsie
you know and was very conflicted by it
it's like dude that makes it worse okay
like that implies that he understood
that the uh the intelligence he was
working with was not like actually legit
intelligence and yet he still continued
and lied to the entire planet
sometimes i see from the liberal news
media it's it's really staggering like
first of all universal louding uh a
praise for colin powell and then when
trump uh messaged this then this outrage
that how could he speak so poorly on
this man
he says hope that happens to me someday
which is hilarious it will by the way it
will because by that point we'll have
like you know
a way worse trump to compare trump to
just like we rehabilitated george w bush
i think it depends when he dies you know
he's not a model of uh health
that doesn't matter the man is the tank
you're you're crazy you think nothing
will take him down you know if eating if
drinking 10 diet cokes a day doesn't
that nothing will no absolutely not his
he he's so he's a truck he's just
nothing will happen to him
first of all
things don't happen to bad people henry
kissinger is still alive how the [ __ ] is
that pogba dick cheney the more evil the
more the longer they live exactly that's
why the good die young yeah
uh i hope that happens to me someday he
was a classic rhino if even that always
being the first to attack other
republicans he made plenty of mistakes
but anyway may he rest in peace love
that it's just
it's kind of first of all he kind of uh
nailed it
yeah
that's a post he's a poster i i i
the best part is for sure uh but anyway
may he rest in peace yeah
it's just like donald trump is the
he is a petty [ __ ] who loves drama he's
so sassy and that's his best quality and
you know it comes out in moments like
this and it's it's just amazing usually
the people have more reverence uh for
people and death but like trump and this
he does this all the time he will tap
dance on your grave oh yeah if you've
ever crossed him in life 100 is [ __ ]
incredible to watch i'll just give you i
don't even think colin powell like
crossed them per se he probably had a
lot of words for don i think he said
something i think he of course of course
he said he voted for hillary or
something like i mean he he was also an
advocate for uh he was an advocate for
barack obama if i'm not mistaken like he
he was the reformed he's the worst kind
of republican i just like
at least these like psychotic q anon
supporters are more honest in their
mania
i find the never trump republican to be
so disingenuous and so awful and their
rehabilitation for the media is
disgusting to me like
you have people who worked in the bush
administration that literally have
untold amounts of blood on their hands
criticizing donald trump does donald
trump deserve criticism of course he
does is donald trump an [ __ ] of
course is he violent of course he's a
narcissistic psychopath yeah all of that
is true and when you sit on the imperial
throne that is you're gonna you're gonna
cause a lot of bloodshed no matter who
it is right and donald trump certainly
did
but the people that are criticizing him
like the never trump republicans that
worked in the bush administration shut
the [ __ ] up spare me your [ __ ]
[ __ ] virtue signaling you are a
monster wait so i'm i'm also fascinated
by the fact that like now we look at
george bush
oh and we go look at this guy he paints
he golfs
he's friends and like uh
he gives candy to michelle obama
but are we can we say for sure like that
trump is worse than bush because like
yeah under
you think
without a doubt well because trump only
had one term bush had you know more time
to really destabilize but you're saying
trump is worse than bush no i'm saying
bush is worse than trump okay sorry i
got that confused yeah i think so too
because
i remember when bush was president [ __ ]
was
i mean the iraq war alone is kind of a
pretty fat feather in the cap the the
war on terror the patriot act like
that's what actually this arena yeah
domestically if you if you think about
like bush's
horrible response to katrina for example
like that was
these are these are all things that we
like swept under the rug i mean trump
botched kovitt obviously but like i feel
like the iraq war has to go down
i mean even if you go to vietnam like
how many vietnamese people did america
kill during vietnam it's probably
nothing compared to the amount of people
that died in iraq um i'm not entirely
sure on the numbers but uh when you when
you have to trivialize your vietnam
it's comparable for sure yeah a lot of
people i thought there was like a few
hundred thousand problem with the
problem with uh
vietnam comparison to just simply iraq
or afghanistan is that like iraq and
afghanistan are not standalone right you
have libya you have what's going on in
yemen you you have what's going on in
syria you have isis so like that
destabilization had
uh a massive
uh exponential uh uh
amount of of human casualties this is
the fallout yeah yeah according to this
oh it's 1.3 chil uh 1.3 million uh
totally [ __ ] that is way worse that is
horrifying
two million civilians died it's hard to
compare though because the vietnam war
was genuinely a civil war as well so
sure i don't know how many of these
deaths were uh i mean i'm sure a lot
were us uh
caused by well i mean there's still
there's still children being born with
uh defects as a conflict yeah i mean
america was american straight up carpet
they were just dropping [ __ ] agent
orange baby oh yeah lighter fluid
basically just burning the whole yeah
that was that was untold amount of war
crimes uh just horrifying we really did
not learn our lesson there and did the
you know identical thing in afghanistan
as well
um the only lesson that the american
government learned there is like how to
cover it from the media point of view
you know yeah because the iraq war
didn't wasn't really
yeah no because until recently it's not
it's been like okay cool no you don't
show caskets like you don't show the the
human casualty on the american side so
that you know we can just like easily
refuse to to look into it and
you know you keep going back to
applebee's and like living your life as
you normally would while you know people
are applebee's the opiate of the masses
we actually have to go to break we'll be
right back we're going to do a quick
break and we got plenty more
to come
[Music]
on the other side of the front my
friends
compared to pumpkin patch photo shoots
and costume planning
you plan you doing any of those pumpkin
patch photo shoots this year oh my god i
love i love that that's my thing
yeah i'm looking forward to those yeah
uh but compared to that shopping for
life insurance with policy genius can be
one of the easiest tasks on your october
to do list policy genius makes it easy
to compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why should you
compare because you can save 50 or more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius and you could be
saving thirteen hundred dollars or more
per year on life insurance by using
policy genius to compare policies
um
the licensed expert policy genius work
for you not the insurance company so you
can trust them to help you navigate
every step of the shopping and buying
process that kind of service has earned
policy genius thousands of five-star
reviews across trustpilot and google and
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirements
for a simple phone call
yeah that's good because they get one
look at me and they'd be like no i'm not
insuring you
is that
is that right you're not insurable
so the phone call works out for me
um this exclusive policy was recently
rated number one by forbes advisor
higher than options from ladder ethos
and bisto pissed out
bismuth
not even doing a good job comparing a
ladder where are you climbing to waste
wasting money yeah that's right policy
genius
getting started is easy first head to
policygenius.com
leftovers a minute you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price and when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and scheduling for free
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
so head on over to policygenius.com
leftovers to get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right testing you
yeah i'm on it dude
thank you guys
[Music]
you got uh let me see the graphic real
quick just double check we're good
stamp.com leftovers with code leftovers
perfect
and
falsehoodgenius.com leftovers looking
good all right let's do it
all right you rolling all right we're
good if you got a small business you
know there's nothing more valuable than
your type so stop wasting it on trips to
the post office
stamps.com makes it easy to mail and
ship right from your computer
save time and money with stamps.com send
letters and packages for less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
badass i know you love the post i do i
love the i love the postal service it's
great
how else are you gonna have little
little chickens delivered i know they
they they're the only ones qualified to
deliver chicken that's right so and i
love my chicken with chicken yeah
see what happens all right
it's gonna be hard when i when i have to
eat it uh since in 1998 stamps.com has
been an indispensable tool for nearly 1
million businesses stamps.com brings the
service of the us post service and ups
shipping right to your computer whether
you're in office sending invoices a side
hustle
etsy shop or a full-blown warehouse
shipping orderstamps.com will make your
life easier all you need is a computer
and standard printer no special supplies
or equipment and with the minute you're
up and running printing official postage
for any letter any package anywhere you
want to send and you'll get exclusive
discounts on postage with shipping from
usps and ups once your mail is ready
just schedule a pickup or drop it off no
traffic no lines cut the confusion out
of shipping
with stamps.com new rate advisor tool
you can compare shipping rates and
timelines to easily find the best option
so save time and money with stamps.com
there's no risk and with our promo code
leftovers you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at top of the homepage and type in
leftovers that's stamps.com promo code
leftoverstamps.com never go to the post
office again
we are back
recharged
reloaded
fueled up
uh now we're gonna get to one of our
main stories here trump's new social
media
uh platform called truth baby
huge announcement
announcement
okay entering the grind
entering the grid oh the grid [ __ ] all
right so here we have it he's announcing
he's going public with it right off the
bat so that'll be good definitely
consider shorting this company
tmt i'm buying all the i'm buying all
the stocks i can
uh the true it's called truth social
network
it's kind of a long
statement but you know not a single
trump supporter is going to read this
[ __ ] okay as a matter of fact one of the
biggest problems with the disc of donald
trump remember when he like originally
came out with that
was that he was just like writing too
much and it wasn't him who was writing
it no shot because like you know donald
trump thrives
under 280 characters okay
well you go beyond that point you go
beyond the breaking point it's just like
he's never writing something that long
okay
so
no one's gonna be reading anything that
long either he's never yeah he's not
reading anything that long he's not
writing anything that long uh which i
respect okay so
it's just well here here's the important
part this is the one he wrote he says i
created truth social
and uh teenage mutant ninja turtles i
think that that reminds me yeah teenage
mutant no turtle gang turtle gang
change me in turtle king totally to
stand up to the tyranny of big tech
that's right by becoming big tech
we live in a world where they
they're not becoming better yeah they're
gonna stay little tech yeah max at best
we live in a world where the taliban has
a huge presence on twitter
yet your favorite american present has
been silenced this is unacceptable
i'm ex i am excited to finally announce
i can't do a good trumpet i'm excited to
send out my first truth on truth social
very soon believe me tmtg was founded
with a mission to give a voice to all
i'm excited to soon begin sharing my
thoughts on truth social and to fight
back against big tech
everyone asked me why does it someone
stand up the big tech
well we will be soon
i mean look
more successful
business people have uh tried and failed
uh you know rumble is like a good
example of this donald trump has never
had a successful business that's what
that's the key it was just so funny to
me but he's like still trying trump
stakes
you're very special trump twitter
basically and um it's gonna be
spectacular to watch this thing fall
apart in fact it hasn't even officially
officially launched yet and it's already
falling apart
it's in beta and somebody already hacked
the [ __ ] website here's somebody
claimed donald j trump's twitter
handle already and pinned a picture of a
pig [ __ ] on his own balls that's an
important announcement that was yeah
i i learned a lot that's the truth so
already off to a hot start
here he is again uh retweeting the fbi
fem oh fbi yeah fanboy [ __ ] inspectors
though
there's no shot
so that that's an important message for
the president
okay
okay
no
conservative that went on the truth
website or whatever the [ __ ] like
there's like i feel like there's eight
people on this website right now and
they're all leftist because like yeah no
one knows what a [ __ ] fanboy is on
the right if they did they would you
telling me he doesn't know what a fanboy
bussie is yeah no
like i just learned about busties a few
weeks ago exactly so so those words are
not used by uh you know
conservative uh divorced ads here he is
uh tweeting at jack apparently the uh is
on uh hit on this new social media hey
freddie's in his uh hoodie
he's looking cute my dog alfredo just
ran in in a doggy hoodie
stalling and profiling um jack unban me
from twitter we get rid of sleepy joe
and turn the fed into a bitcoin mine
deal
lazy truth request anyone know what
melania is up to these days
[Laughter]
so yeah so this is what's going on so
far but nothing will beat the pig
[ __ ] on his own bald pins
i mean parlor parlor had a massive leak
similar to this uh in the beginning uh
all of these platforms that are like
marketed towards conservatives
exclusively often have like really
shoddy
cyber security protections right the
problem is that the
cyber security
you know these hackers are have is so
advanced now it's it's actually super
expensive you need like a massive uh
operation to prevent people from
inflicting and i thought that was a
broke boy and i found out that um it
basically the reason that this keeps
happening to all of these platforms is
they all use this
i think it's like open source social
media platform called mastodon because
they're too lazy to like actually make
their own [ __ ] which is why
it keeps immediately getting figured out
because they all are using like the same
formula and they've all hacked it all
right yeah yeah oh we should make a
social forum using their let's make yeah
if it's that easy yeah we could
um well then it's gonna get hacked
though yeah pretty much immediately it's
basically that's like we could just let
it happen yeah just i'm here to let it
happen yeah
um
the other part about this that does not
make sense is that i mean i love trump
uh and his posts okay i think like i'm
always excited to hear more from donald
trump
but
the reason why a lot of these like gab
rumble
you know
parlor whatever all these like different
kinds of websites ultimately fail
is because there are no libs to own
there you want to own the libs that's
the whole fun of the game is like if you
can't trigger the libs then
conservatives have nothing well they and
also they go there to get mad like
that's what they like so if you go there
and it's all just a huge echo chamber
you're not look you're just looking at
people saying the same [ __ ] everywhere
you gotta see people owning lips like
you said you gotta quote tweet somebody
um yeah and be like these guys
this guy's a chinese communist somebody
sent a bomb threat to this guy yeah so
without that it just turns into you know
a
nazi gathering because those people do
have like an ideological position that
is still inherently reactionary they
love owning the libs as well
but uh
they have a another goal you know what i
mean right but you're right because the
pals and the nazis they're not
necessarily looking to own libs they're
just looking for a place where they can
congregate and they've been kicked off
every other yeah social media so for
them it's fresh pasture
and for everyone else that's not a pile
or a nazi which is probably the majority
of them let's be honest i mean there's a
lot of there's a lot of adjacent uh you
know file adjacent nazi adjacent
conservatives so you know uh it just
turns into some very bizarre
uh situation that's what happens when
you don't have like any sort of
restrictions and even then these
websites do have restrictions as a
matter of fact donald trump's website
famously the truth one has restrictions
yeah i'm getting to that a lot of really
great ones well well before we talk
about that you want to show this first
so here's don jr our favorite friend of
the show friend of the show made us a
cameo wished us well yeah um promoting
trump's new uh social media and free
network for people to be able to
communicate to exercise your first
amendment rights and so tonight my
father signed a definitive merger
agreement
to form what will ultimately be the
trump media and technology group and
truth social a platform for everyone to
express their feelings big tech and all
of those on the left for so long sean
have been saying well if you don't like
the rules that we really enforce only
one way on our platforms go create your
own and so we did just that so that's
going to launch very soon we're going to
be in beta testing in the next few weeks
full launch uh first quarter of 22
it's going to be exciting and we're
looking to give a voice back to the
american people you and free yeah yeah
nothing says giving a voice back to the
american people by like making them sign
up to another website that's inevitably
going to get owned as it has already
with massive data leaks uh where
you know conservatives complain about
like uh having their accounts uh banned
off platforms so they can't speak to
anyone anymore on those platforms
because they're violating the terms of
service so what the alternative is to go
to a website where no one is there
it's the same it's like not having a
twitter account is the same as having a
[ __ ] truth account you know for sure
truth social well they say he says you
know he's combating the tyranny of big
tech do you find it ironic that after
you sign up
they beg you to share it on twitter and
facebook of course
yeah yeah
and massive dumps
i mean they love facebook too so
facebook is where they thrive um here is
some of some uh snippets from their
um terms of service
the terms of service on trump's new
social site is very specific you can't
harass or annoy the staff dude this is
the first this is the the
free speech you you can't annoy the
staff yeah
that's right that's free speech
and trump is staff i mean he's gonna own
it so if you annoy trump like what does
that mean annoy like do you even have to
interact with him can i just be minding
my own business and then he's annoyed by
me and then he bans me yeah you you say
that uh no actually trump you're wrong
the met gala was tasteful and he's like
annoying you're wrong brady carter is a
loser and you know he will he'll be just
banning everybody yeah
so here's what it says you cannot trick
again trick is like very
broad defraud or mislead us or other
users
specifically in any attempt to learn
sensitive account information
i mean at least they know their audience
like this is literally like please don't
uh you know don't steal the information
of like old racists that came onto this
website by telling them that you can you
have iraqi dinars
trick us though yeah please don't trick
us no funny business yeah they just
write no funny business yeah we like to
troll uh use any information obtained
from the site in order to harass abuse
or harm other persons again it's like
what do you mean obtained from the site
like
if
i see it's just so
broad yeah yeah i mean this like it just
reads like uh boilerplate uh
legal terms of service with like
national yeah this is like weird no i
know i know but like with a weird trump
seasoning on it i feel like trump wrote
this himself this is not legal language
i still don't believe he knows how to
write so yeah it's possible we haven't
seen evidence here that you cannot
harass annoy
dude no lawyer has ever written annoy
into [ __ ] terms of service yeah
harassment is like what covers that
usually you know what i mean you cannot
write annoy
intimidate or threaten any of our
employees or agents engaged in providing
any portion of the site to you it's
because
i'm sorry but no no it's because all of
the lawyers died from coven
all their [ __ ] lawyers are dead now
so like
they have like a paralegal type of [ __ ]
up you know what i mean they have like
one guy left that's awesome
yeah
yeah they're all too busy dying in the
hospital okay you can't disparage
tarnish
or otherwise harm in our opinion
us or the sight you can't you can't
disparage the sight
yeah because you can't make fun of us on
the side this is some real how was this
free speech this is some real snowflake
[ __ ] right here this is you can't you
can't hurt our feelings but that's but
that is like this is brutally honest
like conservatives don't want free
speech they just want you to shut the
[ __ ] up if you ever tell them that
they're wrong you know what i mean
that's where that's where that comes
from and free speech protection is
exclusively center around being able to
say and do hate speech and hateful acts
so exactly you gotta like it all or like
none of it yeah it's just like you can't
tarnish you can't say naughty things
about us or any of our staff
on our website
free speech yeah like i love when people
always say like mccarthyist this is
mccarthyis it's like [ __ ] who
was the victim of that you know what i
mean communists like time and time again
the real victims of
free speech or the the real people that
have never been covered by free speech
protections that are supposedly
incredibly expansive here in the united
states have been leftists you know
uh specifically you know black leftists
as well like the black panther party
like they were so not covered by free
speech that their leaders were executed
by the american government so
you know well even recently someone like
uh
colin kaepernick is like
yeah even in the private sector [ __ ]
free speech yeah nobody on this freedom
free speech website is gonna [ __ ]
be singing his praise but anyway it'll
be interesting to do like ban olympics
when this launches
like if you're just
[ __ ] on trump and the replies
uh if he's just going to be outright
banning people what's uh
i don't think that many people are going
to use this because it's going to be
there's no there's no runway like they
just kind of drop this out of nowhere
they didn't tease it like i feel like
i've put more uh time into like my
[ __ ]
merchandise than this [ __ ] you know what
i mean it's like they just like kind of
dropped this out of nowhere they went on
fox news yeah so it's a build up right
now you can sign up for the beta and
it's launching in the first quarter of
next year i think
i know but like i don't know i just i
feel like no it's gonna be a disaster
there's no question about it and also
how do you make
how do they make money off this
i don't know but they they mur the whole
thing is so mysterious to me they merged
with a publicly traded company this is
going to be publicly traded out the gate
and i'm telling you if you want to get
rich short this company because this is
going straight to like a meteor to earth
i know but have you heard that
additionally the tiny meat turtle gang
intends to launch a subscription video
on demand service oh yeah the the ninja
turtle meet gang plus yeah and it will
feature non-awoke entertainment dude
you're
like woke-ism non-woke entertainment i
feel like woke has become this like word
and when i hear it i'm like ugh non-woke
entertainment what does that mean like
uh
we're gonna be racist
please subscribe i'm going to be so
racist
yeah
yeah man i'm this is going to be [ __ ]
awesome to follow though because yeah
they're producing original content
um
and i just can't wait to see you i just
can't wait to see it it's gonna be
fantastic it's gonna be like every other
[ __ ] oan you know newsmax style uh
news coverage that looks like they
always have like that weird
filter almost where it looks like
there's vaseline rubbed on the lens you
know what i mean when you watch when you
watch any of these like super [ __ ]
far right news coverages like you're
like what happened why why is the lens
so why are you so crusty and greasy what
is going on there that's what the entire
thing is going to look like if
they even develop anything at that yeah
i'm surprised because like he's such a
horrible businessman
this is the quibby of of regular media
is
trump's new media company will be funded
with the help of digital world
acquisitions a blink
check company based in miami what is a
blank check company
it basically means a company that
doesn't have any specific business plan
or direction
weird
shady d-wag
according to the press release issued on
wednesday night d-wag
a so-called special purpose acquisition
company
yeah we'll help i love their acronyms
are off the rails tmtg wag and teenage
mutant turtle gang
become a publicly traded company
the ceo of the company patrick orlando
is also ceo of yoon hong international
bro what which is an international yeah
which itself is an international blank
check company incorporated in the cayman
islands with headquarters and wuhan
china that's right
what that's why i sent this funded by a
company stationed in wuhan china
yeah what the [ __ ] yeah conservatives
love wuhan now that's right what
happened to wuhan flu
yeah
um
now it's wuhan
steve bannon was caught with another
like uh
chinese billionaire on a yacht remember
when the when the u.s postal service
secret agents like actually apprehended
them
for doing like wire fraud for that and
charity fraud yeah for the border wall
thing yeah
they love i mean these guys they
i wonder what's the chinese interest in
funding this i guess they just like to
destabilize uh no there is
uh there are different factions within
china
like there are some very wealthy chinese
oligarchs that are
as as anti-state as you can get as anti
ccp as you can get um and then there are
like psychotic
hyper right wing
uh uh cults like falun gong
uh that actually fund the epoch times
have you ever heard of epoch times yeah
so epoch times is like a right-wing
website
that's uh they're they're backed by the
falun gong cult and they're anti-chinese
state of course they work side by side
with the cia for their anti-chinese
state uh leanings doesn't the government
wouldn't they if there was like a real
big anti-state movement in china don't
they just come in and [ __ ] they
disappear in the no they operate outside
of it oh they're not they operate yeah i
mean a lot of their a lot of that stuff
is just like outside of the
control of like you know
um the chinese communist party but
that's
that's where it uh that's where it comes
from like a lot of this uh a lot of
these like billionaires and millionaires
that are still like very wealthy and
whatnot they
uh will oftentimes have like
anti-chinese sentiment and can
get broad freedoms worldwide to run
around and do whatever they want
and i mean i don't know about this
particular person
but um you know if there's money to be
made they're going to do it you know i
don't think there's like a destabilizing
interest right there right
well here he is on hannity it's probably
good too
he's doing the rounds oh wait is this
what we were just here we just
thought he was on tucker
um
so anyway
let's see yeah
uh you can also get oh this is
interesting there here's another one you
can get banned on
truth
for using too many capital letters this
one really blew me away because that's
like trump's thing
like it's just like randomly all capsing
words and stuff the site's terms of
service however lists some rules that
would hamstring trump himself the site
will ban for instance excessive use of
capital letters
i don't that's so sure why but let me
let the people use capital letters i
mean it's like this you know let the
people old hogs love doing that
you know having the caps lock stuck
um man none of this makes sense which is
also part of the reason why i think at
least it's not gonna pop off well i'm
gonna be watching eagerly
we'll be following it on this show and
uh boy i'm just so excited for this new
social media empire
suspicious that this is happening right
as facebook said that they were
rebranding i'm just gonna
i don't know maybe this is the new
facebook
i would not be surprised if suck was
teamed up with trump
i love it to bring you
no zuckerberg loves making money this is
not this is not a money maker if i if
trump if someone else was doing this
trump would call it like wuhan book
wuhan book or something yeah book
oh for sure
oh uh the other the other thing like
getter was another website that was like
uh
owned immediately and it was overrun by
hentai and isis content and videos of
like beheadings and whatnot yeah wasn't
that one what was the other con
the one with the the chat room where
people would come in and do like
speeches and stuff what was that one oh
oh that's like uh
crap that's like some clubhouse
clubhouse yeah i heard that like they're
the most one of the most popular genres
in clubhouse is just openly anti-semitic
neo-nazi uh oh yeah that's not
surprising
chat room so it's always funny because
like these guys will like come up with a
unique way of making people communicate
with one another and then immediately a
week later twitter is like we're
announcing you know rooms and then it's
like you're done now now clubhouse is
done yeah you know and facebook will do
that instagram will do that whatever um
so moving on to our next story we
touched on cops a little bit but uh
following up on that
cops are quitting their jobs over the
covid mandate
covet has become the leading cause of
death bringing home the bacon you like
that i love that oink oink
uh covert has become the leading cause
of death for officers despite law
enforcement's being among the first
group eligible to receive vaccines in
the end of 2020
thank you
the total
the total stands at
nearly 500
covid 19 related deaths
since the start of the pandemic compared
to 94 from gunfire from the same period
which by the way when people say gunfire
remember
that doesn't always mean gunfire from
you know the bad guys yeah the the bad
guys often
more often than you would think is is
friendly fire
um specifically in uh colorado or
washington state where like a lot of
this stuff started popping out uh
popping off there was one that was like
a like a officer in training shot the
other officer who was training him in
the back of the head holy while they
were engaging in yeah i mean that stuff
happens all the time well i was you know
i followed the brianna
oh god i forgot her last name what was
her yeah brianna taylor thing yeah and
when you watch the recreations of the
shootings i mean these cops are so
irresponsible one of they're just
literally one of the cops outside
i think the only one that got charged
yeah was just firing recklessly into the
building like in every direction and he
could have easily killed someone even
another cop they often do and uh he was
the only one that got charged for
recklessly discharging his gun yeah
because the other the other cops were
considered to be like uh you know well
within
their rights to shoot
um so they
they saw the
the material damages that that other cop
caused by shooting into like other
apartment buildings as well
as like a worse offense than straight up
murdering someone you know knowing uh i
know it's crazy
that story was awful but also you know
no knock raids regular currents
uh yet another yet another instance of
like a lack of accountability
horrible training uh and and no no
de-escalation measures like put in place
it's just awful so here is cause of
death of law enforcement
uh you can see from 2001 to 2021
there's a sudden spike in deaths
um yeah cops are getting absolutely
murdered like just straight up [ __ ]
murdered by covet yeah the felonious
deaths are actually down uh
while their job becomes less dangerous
according to this graph more and more
dying
of
covet quite a bit and um they don't want
to get vaccinated for the record like
uh so cause of death for law enforcement
obviously 9 11 related is like in the
aftermath of 9 11 there's still like
cancer or whatnot yeah that's right
insane looking at like how
yeah how many people actually died from
that too yeah well that's because a lot
of the cops that died they die uh on the
on the job because like they're driving
recklessly that's a huge one okay they
drive like [ __ ] [ __ ] and then
they get into collisions and they die if
they're not killing other people like
the motorcyclist that was like murdered
by a [ __ ] cop i think in florida like
last week
um and then they die of heart failure
very regularly heart disease
and that's considered again an
on-the-job on the line death
they have other non-fallacious and then
same with covet like they they consider
these to they i mean they tack up the
they tack up the number they put that on
the tally even if they're dying of covid
and they're dying to covet quite a lot
as you can see you know and
um which makes sense they're out there
they're with the masses they're
breathing people's you know in space so
yeah they should be vaccinated for sure
and therefore it also
is implied that if these guys are out
there doing all this and dying of covid
that the transmission of kovit to police
is extremely high and that they have the
potential to be spreading that [ __ ]
around they absolutely are they they
absolutely are like they will be super
spreaders guaranteed if not vaccinated
yeah
and uh of course in the most predictable
way they have decided that covet is not
the real problem the vaccine mandates
are the real problem
and so they're quitting their jobs do me
a favor dan pull up the the video of the
new york city cops throwing the guy at
the subway who asked why aren't they
wearing masks not only are they
not getting vaccinated they're refusing
even to wear masks
in new york there was a video going
viral yesterday a guy asked him he's
like yo you're in the subway why aren't
you guys wearing masks
and they kicked him out of the [ __ ]
subway yeah and he's like i'm the boss
of the subway you know they were
particularly stealing the guy he had
already paid his ticket his pair
these [ __ ]
yeah they're above the law
clearly 100
so according to the person who shot the
video all the guy did
was ask if they would please uh put on
their masks so here's the result of that
they're not even like uh
they're not even pretending to care
about masks they don't even have it
around their neck
they don't have it anywhere they're in a
closed
space bro i feel like if there's one
place you should definitely wear masses
in your subway yeah okay like yeah even
even if there is no cover you should
probably still wear a mask
for sure it doesn't even smell good like
the at least the mask will protect you
from the smells you know what i'm saying
like jesus christ and they didn't they
didn't even arrest him or like pretend
like he had done anything wrong i mean
they just exactly shoved them outside
because exactly why not
and they told him he can't come back in
yeah just like okay i guess i won't
commute commute home now nothing wrong
they would have arrested him right
instead they stole his fare disrupted
his day
and continued on mask list in violation
of the city's own law
uh [ __ ] the police
i mean it's just like
these are
i like covering these minor
inconveniences that the cops regularly
subject people to
because it really shows the disdain that
they have are the people that they're
supposed to protect and serve right and
it extends from that small interaction
uh all the way up to the the actual
infractions the violent altercations the
escalation on you know uh routine
traffic stops and whatnot and it's all
the same mentality that they have which
is that like i will enforce my authority
upon you no matter what okay and i will
never be held accountable so i can get
away with it so i'm gonna lay off you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna do
whatever the [ __ ] i can here to to make
sure that you listen to me and
i'm not one of those people that says
like we need to abolish the police force
in its entirety i understand that there
is still a necessity for some formation
whether it's democratically organized or
not some formation that will at least
create a presence of law and order so i
totally understand that but
police historically and certainly in
contemporary society has never filled
that role for marginalized communities
they operate like an occupying force in
black and brown neighborhoods and in a
lot of instances they've been trained uh
they've they they have counterterrorism
training uh that that you see when
they're dealing with like black lives
matter protesters for example kettling
and corralling gassing people like right
it's completely unacceptable
and uh at the slightest bit of criticism
they lose their [ __ ] [ __ ] and that's
uh also because they're all all [ __ ]
hogs they're 84 percent of the police
force is like i love donald trump i'm
voting for donald trump
yeah there i think it just like when
you're so used to this ultimate
authority and power when people question
that even in the slightest way it just
you you're just so used to doing
whatever the [ __ ] you want and never
being talked back to by anyone that uh
it really just corrupts the mind being
part of that cult and it does seem like
a call the this whole police union [ __ ]
and think about this way when you're
accustomed to a lifetime of privilege
equality feels like oppression
for cops that's on overdrive like we
think about the victimhood mentality
conservatives have where they're like oh
my god starbucks no longer has christmas
uh stuff on their cups that's the killer
brothers war civil war yeah vaccine
mandates civil war that is
the the mentality that they have
but this time they're like you know well
armed very dangerous and also willing to
do things like they can rob you of your
freedom they can
rob you of your life
and in some instances not even you know
go to jail for it not even get not not
even be fired yeah let alone go to jail
exactly so
it is just completely [ __ ] from top to
bottom and of course there is uh no no
mechanism to uh
to enforce any sort of accountability uh
the the defund the police movement was
uh
like
was met with so much criticism for the
mainstream media uh rather than like
trying to describe the the intentions of
that movement which was created by
activists on the street they're not
focus group testing their [ __ ]
message it's like black lives matter
um
and uh instead of being like well defund
the police means like taking away some
of these insane resources that we are
affording the police force uh all around
the country unconditionally at a time
when like you know education needs
resources social workers need resources
but all of that is being sent and spent
on this violent paramilitary
organization
um
and and we need to change that dynamic a
little bit instead of accurately
describing those demands they were like
no this is [ __ ] this is terrible
it's also freaking people out while
simultaneously continuing to freak
people out
and
you if you watch
a lot of right-wing media you hear
non-stop about how you know the police
have been defunded and that's why
there's crime everywhere the police have
been defunded this is crazy it's
[ __ ] the police have not been
defunded yeah anyway i've been anywhere
the total is around 800 million dollars
so far uh that has been taken off the
top of the police budgets that means uh
like uh you know scaling back one
percent right of the police uh
additional revenue that they were gonna
get from the city like the additional
amount of money that they were gonna get
they're still the the the number one uh
you know budget in most cities right
yeah um but
even if you take like a little bit off
the top they're like oh [ __ ] we're dying
or you're killing me you're killing me
right now i'm literally dying
and civil war yeah civil war and to put
that into perspective 800 million
dollars seems like a lot of money right
yeah well you know certain cities have
700 million
uh uh los angeles has a budget
of what is it 1.5 billion dollars and
it's slated to be three billion dollars
like that's nothing when you take like
10 million from the top and then give it
back to the school program you know what
i mean to try to at least it sounds like
civil war yeah to at least like focus on
the root cause of crime that we know is
that you know crime usually comes from
like class disparity desperation if you
actually invest it's like addressing the
uh symptom rather than the cause right
it's like if you use that money back
into poor neighborhoods and school and
after school programs and
then uh
uh yeah and
there's gonna be less crime yeah it
leads to a decreasing crime there's a
trackable decrease in crime in areas
where there are more after-school
programs and whatnot
but
we never we never want to do that
because it's so much easier to just like
keep giving
money so they can keep buying the guns
that the military can no longer use you
know what i mean what are they gonna do
though without the uh black man do crime
yeah for the record it was
840 million in cuts across the entire
country uh the lapd budget is 1.76
billion the budget of san francisco
police department alone is 700 million
baltimore 536 million yeah i was pretty
shocked i saw la's
um city budget and the cops
was like
over 50 percent of the budget like by
far yeah sound right uh yeah something
along those lines uh
i i and i talk to cops a lot
unfortunately i have to interact with
them for
you know obvious reasons
and obvious reasons well you know
similar stuff that happens to you from
time to time you know what i mean oh
so yes anyway uh and and every [ __ ]
time dude every time it's like oh we
hate uh the we hate that our resources
are spread so thin it's like oh we can't
handle it it's like well you know maybe
you shouldn't handle some of that stuff
some of that stuff could absolutely be
handled by social workers yeah people
who are trained to deal with for sure
yeah
um but uh it's one of the cushiest gigs
you can have in america and yet we have
some brave patriots right here
giving up here is the yeah the the the
beautiful job yeah here's the absolute
cushiest gig you can have
yeah they've got great benefits
incredible pay great benefits
here here are these brave patriots
giving up massive
overtime pay off yeah uh
seattle fire and police to charge for
non-compliance with the vaccine mandate
turn in their boots into city hall and
declare it's civil war
yeah this is the oppress so this this is
the victim
mentality that like i think you made a
great point when you're used to
privilege equality seems like oppression
and uh boy this is a solemn walk man
these guys have been through the ringer
they've had enough
we've had enough of your oppression
damn this is song dude this is serious
wow
yeah turning in those boots yeah it's uh
it's it's madness dude it's madness what
what will happen now bedlam absolute
bedlam here's more
oh what is that this is this la city
budget right
so the police is
53.4
you know that's crazy
and then what where's education
well education comes from the education
comes from the state and yeah so it's uh
but i mean some does but i mean maybe a
good thing to look at would be like
parks or like libraries you know public
works i'm surprised the libraries even
get five percent bro
i thought it'd be lower than that yeah
who needs books brother we need more we
need to make sure that every cop can
have an armored personnel carrier that
you can't even [ __ ] drive and lost
we need anti-artillery tanks
we need that microwave gun the the
active denial system that uh you know
you just like the microwave gum they're
scrap they're scrambling people's brains
with no no no there's a there's a
there's an active denial system that the
us military created it's kind of like
it's like elrad too long-range acoustic
devices these are all like
anti-riot measures that they originally
used in iraq and then they started using
on american citizens of course
immediately the lrad is like so insanely
loud that you can't stay there if you
ask cops though and they're using it
like they do in portland all the time
they'll say oh it's just a pa system no
the [ __ ] it's not [ __ ] it's literally a
weapon and the active denial system lit
straight up
uh burns like boils the water particles
like a microwave does
on your skin so it seems it feels like
your skin's on fire wow yeah uh i don't
know if it's been in use in the united
states yet but uh you know it's out
there dan put that graph back up real
fast i mean that tells the whole story
in a in a society when you're spending
52
of your budget
on the police i mean just imagine the
utopia we could live in where you even
just cut that in half
and distribute it against other
beautiful so like if we had parks and
libraries and cities and stuff like that
and city public works just imagine what
a beautiful blessed city this could be
oh and uh that was actually 2019 uh 2020
here's uh 2010 that's what i don't get
now it's even more like why is it going
that's what i'm saying they they like
why does it go up what is it it's always
going up but why
because crime that's why there's the
only way to tackle it down isn't it like
crime is down well crime historically is
down from uh you know the 90s and
whatnot and uh but overall like crime
has increased and the reason why he's a
democrat he's a liberal but of course
liberals love cops uh the the thing is
the way the reason why crime is
increasing especially in like cities and
whatnot is because homelessness is
increasing it's because people are in
half and do public housing yeah like if
you eliminated some of the material
needs
that these people have
for survival
you would eliminate a gigantic chunk of
the need to do crime people aren't doing
crime because they're bad okay so this
is 5.4 billion so the police are getting
half of that so 2.2 uh 2.7 billion yeah
imagine the public housing projects you
could do the
parks the la the libraries the shelters
i mean that is so much money you want to
know where a lot of that police budget
is spent tell me
lawsuits
not all of it but like a big chunk of
that goes to malpractice lawsuits paying
victims
because yeah you you hear about this
people sue uh this the city or the state
for a cop killed oh a cop accidentally
killed my spouse when i was in the car
damn and then you [ __ ] sue the state
and you get like a massive 50 million
dollar payout well yeah well if you're
white if you're white yeah we pay that
and the cop gets to continue working
yeah
well he's got to do that he had to he
has to kill uh people come on
i didn't realize that so much of it i
actually love to see a breakdown of how
much of that budget goes to just
lawsuits well um kenneth maja is running
for comptroller and he actually does a
pretty good job shouts out the shouts
out the kenneth um
wait hold on uh yeah he's he's a
certified public accountant housing
justice activist and he's running for
los angeles city controller in 2022
and um he often has like these big
breakdowns
of the la budget regularly
um where he talks about you know
uh the the proposed budgets and he'll
he'll like break down all of the
different uh ways that people's uh you
know spend that revenue do we have intel
on how much it goes to like settlements
and lawsuits i'm looking to see if i can
find it off the top of my head but i
don't know if there is uh one of those
yeah this is some sad [ __ ] man shame on
the mayor for even approving that what a
[ __ ] nightmare yeah yesterday the
lapd sent 30 to 40 cops a helicopter a
canine unit over a homeless person that
was in a vacant house and then they
found no one
a helicopter yeah for one homeless dude
in a hot vacant house yeah on sycamore
and sunset boulevard uh hollywood
uh you know
two days ago now by the way ice when i
lived in woodland hills there was always
every [ __ ] afternoon there and it was
like a relatively safe neighborhood i
think there was a but it was right off
the freeway so i didn't know what was
going on there was a lapd helicopter
that would fly super [ __ ] low and
circle my house like for like 20 minutes
every day and then we found out that one
of our neighbors is related to that cop
so he would come do a free ride over the
over the neighborhood every day for 20
minutes in the lapd copter and just like
say hi to
isn't that [ __ ] annoying how much
money is that oh it's
i was like i'm going to call the [ __ ]
i'm going to do something i'm going to
complain
[ __ ] up and it was it's actually scary
because sometimes she'd be on the
intercom saying [ __ ] and it looks like
he's because i'd be in my backyard
chilling and it looked like he was like
specifically there [ __ ] with me yeah
yeah that's crazy
i remember when that was happening i
didn't
i don't think you ever told me that that
you found out that that's what it was
about yeah just yeah even though he was
being gangsta god that's crazy i didn't
know what was going on but imagine the
amount of money spent how much is that
lapd helicopter those things are decked
out like i don't know 50 million plus
dollars i mean i don't know is there
expensive though yeah um but yeah
joyriding doing stuff like that it's
definitely a part of it and um they get
away with doing all that because hey
they're the they're the last line of
defense between you and the poorest okay
so if the poor's ever god forbid if they
ever rise up you know you need cops on
your side people always say
we found a poor and a vacant house and
we sent the swat team 10 canine units
and 20 helicopters and and people always
say like oh what are you going to do
with you know when uh a crime happens
like who are you going to call it's like
listen crimes happen all the time to me
specifically and uh and others i know
and
i i have yet to see a police officer be
like all right we we dealt with this uh
here you go and you know that's
anecdotal but uh
uh there's also data available that like
the cops are not preventing crime okay
they are for the most part doing their
very best to i guess stop it but the
main focus in my opinion of the police
force is to maintain a presence
of law and order that like we have rules
we have to live by okay
that
we all abide by to the best of our
abilities in society and cops are their
presence is supposed to create that
order of
order actually that presence of order um
but uh in a lot of instances especially
in poor neighborhoods uh and and black
and brown communities in black and brown
neighborhoods their presence
unfortunately is disorder and
lawlessness for the most part for all
the way from civil assets forfeiture uh
to to just like routine traffic stops
that end up with like serious
escalations and sometimes even death
it's just a terrifying situation to live
under when the government that's
supposed to protect you
it says protect and serve on the side of
the [ __ ] cop car
when when you see that cop car you're
like oh [ __ ] here we go again that's not
good you know so just do your [ __ ]
job is what i say by the way in 2020 it
cost uh 1 200 per hour
to fly a lapd helicopter without
accounting for the pilot's salary so
that's a lot of money blown just to [ __ ]
with me
yeah anyway here's more here's more
troopers uh former troopers from
washington state patrol laid their boots
at the state capital to show
those lost because of the statewide
vaccine mandate uh what about the ones
died from kovid nope that's not
important that's unimportant are you
[ __ ] kidding me yeah this one is
incredible they're not dead they just
they had to [ __ ] they're on leave by the
way the funniest thing is like they're
not dead you [ __ ] look like local
news that's local news participating in
the reactionary propaganda to show those
lost because of statewide mandates like
dude you are literally an emmy
award-winning
local [ __ ] journalist dude what are
you doing you're gonna say lost those
lost like they [ __ ] died the mandate
because of the mandate what are you
talking about yeah it's like
and this is why i always like whenever
people are like liberal news media she
continues uh 127 people
are now unemployed damn they're dead
we need to go to the capitol
we need to take time and
for the they've
they're on leave
they're on leave yeah i mean lost them
they're probably going to cycle out some
of these guys are going to go and
probably work in like [ __ ] one of
those states where they don't have said
mandates or like where you know there's
a republican governor who doesn't give a
[ __ ] you know what i mean
oh yeah people yelled at her verify she
said to clarify by lost i mean resources
that will no longer be available
uh while they are already dealing with
shortages apologies for any confusion
are you st you want an emmy you don't
know
uh
yeah here yeah that that's that's pretty
bad yeah always always passive voice
always using state patrol was the name
yeah
yeah
you guys saw the videos right i mean we
have some of those videos of like
i mean these guys are theater kids too
that's the other that's my favorite part
about this entire process is like it's
so dramatic you know what i mean here
the 17 year old the 17-year veteran
tearfully says goodbye forced out by the
vaccine mandate his wife is the dispatch
operator of 15 years oh this is so sad
you know what you could have done got
the vaccine
i love this i mean tell me the cop skull
thing is not true tell me a lie right
now dude that's a hot dog right there
due to my personal choice to take a
moral stand against
for
medical freedom i
enjoy being a security guard wherever i
thought service for the last time today
after nearly 17 years of serving the
citizens of the state of washington it
has been my honor and privilege to work
alongside all of you
i want to take a moment to thank those
that have helped me be successful to be
safe and to go home every day
at the end of each shift
wait hold on zach type in some sad music
we need to set the tone
[Music]
this is just this is way too tragic i
mean
this is just hit me with it please this
is too uh sincere too powerful of a
moment
we're gonna have to go take his boots to
the capitol first yeah because he's been
like we've lost him today yeah the
ripping of that velcro
is a relief to my wife and kids yeah i
want to
admonish each of you knowing
that despite what the pressure sir uh
this is for emergency use yeah
we all know in this district
on the 19th there will be 51 of the 75
troopers available
and only 7 of the 11 sergeants
so please please please
take care of each other
time to do crimes boys this is a good
opportunity care of each other
be safe
and make sure you all go home at the end
of each day
this guy's
annoying i mean they're they're such
[ __ ] theater kids dude like that that
has like theater kid energy you missed
it in the end
he thought should i go back okay there's
a point where he does a pause
and then he repeats what he's saying and
it's like dude it is so
you are so he turned him up and the
music down a little bit because i can't
really hear what he's saying
i want to say he's been a pleasure to
work with for the last
almost guys don't you have [ __ ] to do
though for real like there's an
emergency service that's your wife he
has his wife on the dispatcher's side
talking
around this is so dumb
can't you meet them in person like don't
you know them
i'm honored to have been your dispatcher
but mostly proud to be your wife our
future is right
thank you so much for your service one
time he's crying what a [ __ ]
sorry doc's masculine by my side
thank you for being by my side
martha [ __ ] these guys man it's awesome
well like you said they've got the best
cushy's job
all you have to do is take a [ __ ]
vaccine like every [ __ ] federal employee
and there's people out there who can't
even [ __ ] find like minimum wage jobs
and you're sitting here
like a little it's been an honor like
first of all nothing happened bro you're
leaving of your own uh volition yeah
this isn't tragic
no it's called medical freedom ethan you
don't understand it hyporites
i have hippo rights
it's like it's like these guys are you
know they're
these are my hippo rods they they're
just so used to just like getting their
way this is the this is really funny too
this is the last time you hook for me in
a patrol car and jay ensley can kiss my
ass
washington state trooper
signs off after 22 years
fired
by the governor for being unvaccinated a
reminder like
a lot of cops are dying to covet in the
state of washington okay nobody gives a
[ __ ] about that though obviously because
covet is fake
this is my final sign-off um after 22
years of serving the citizens of the
state of washington
um being asked to leave because i am
dirty yeah
i am dirty fatalities he is injuries
i've worked sick yeah i mean dude like
bro he's like i work sick bro that's
kind of a problem dude that's not good
dude like i've been coughing i've been
coughing on him
i've had coffin i've spread it to at
least 10 000 folks around here yeah
i'm protecting and serving them straight
into the tombstone right straight into
the grave
played sick
um we buried lots of friends later what
the [ __ ] is that you guys i'd like to
thank the um
citizens of yakima county as well as
they're happy to see you guys officers
within the valley without you guys i
would have been very successful and
you've kept me safe and got me home to
my family every night
um
thank you for that
um
i wish i could say more but um this is
it so
state 10 34 this is the last time you'll
hear me in a state patrol car
james can kiss my ass five and four
he drops it on his balls mike drop on
the
you for your balls here let me see the
mic drop on the ball
he didn't even flinch though my man's
got balls of steel thank you for your 22
years
of service to the citizens so scripted
you've taken on many roles in your time
with the troll yeah in your first year
you delivered a baby while on patrol in
bremerton you've been a theory theory
instructor oh she's definitely reading a
script yeah you delivered a baby you did
this you did that
yeah is there anything else you wanted
me to say oh yeah and uh i just hit my
balls i'm not gonna read this you're
gonna have to pay me another hundred
bucks if you want me to read a paper
specialist and reconstructionist peer
support member part of the chaplaincy
board and a cbd trooper you've been a
great role model and mentor for all
young troopers serving in the area by
sharing your knowledge and experience
throughout the years just kids
vaccinated [ __ ] if you care about
protecting and serving the community you
should be willing to make that small
[ __ ] sacrifice i don't even know if
you could call it a sacrifice but like
here's your ability here's your chance
to serve and protect don't spread covet
to people you apparently care about
nope and and you know protect yourself
too like you're wearing a [ __ ]
bulletproof vest you claim that like you
know uh your job is incredibly stressful
and terrifying
in washington state as a state trooper
the most terrifying thing is probably
[ __ ] getting buddy [ __ ] by a
trainee you know what i mean who pops in
the back of the head friendly fire yeah
exactly or like you know uh
[ __ ] having a heart attack while
you're like chasing after a 14 year old
teenager for the crime of skating you
know what i mean like
so you know those are those are the real
terrifying propositions that await you
right it is pretty great to see them all
just and and then you know you're over
here [ __ ] crying about a vaccine it
shows it perfectly shows and captures
that like a lot of the stuff that you
hear a lot of the rhetoric that you hear
about like cop lives are in danger blue
lives matter thin blue line like it's
all [ __ ] if you're you're scared of
a little boo-boo from a vaccine you know
what i mean like you have every
opportunity to get this [ __ ] thing
you're not getting it uh
because you're terrified of it because
you think like global control is gonna
happen or some [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] is
the reason because you watch too much
fox news and
that to me proves like
your job is not that terrifying like if
your job if you're literally getting
[ __ ] a hail of bullets every time you
step out of your cop car you're not
gonna give a [ __ ] about being protected
from [ __ ] covid that has killed a
bunch of your colleagues already well
there was i didn't know this but like we
learned in the last episode they're like
the 22 most dangerous uh that's right in
america behind uh what was the one in
front of it something landscapers yeah
landscapers yeah
yeah escaping lives matter absolutely
we're at about two hours which is our
limit
had a lot of fun
had some good times
had some informative conversations and
some informative times i was gonna i was
gonna like i said i would try to be a
little bit more lighthearted but i get
so serious it's fine because i feel like
i have a
you know i feel like i have a more
serious like duty here to you know uh
provide additional information and
whatnot or my perspective maybe that's
the reason
we'll get the flow i think it's fun we
had a good up i mean i enjoy it every
time we have a great episode
it's episode five we'll hit our stride
around uh i'd say uh 40.
okay good these things are marathons no
but i think it's going great i love our
conversations i love the whole all the
topics and stuff i love to talk about
you're super knowledgeable and i love
that
and i just can't wait for more trump
yeah
i mean he's horrible i can't
i don't know what the [ __ ] going to
happen in the country but he's
inevitable like um
like a covet death when you refuse to
take the [ __ ] vaccine and you're
running around who's the villain from
fantastic inevitable like thanos yeah
trump still arrives yeah all right guys
thanks for watching this is uh
ethan and hassan in the 10 trillion
dollar studio
protected
uh by nuclear fallout we have
anti-aircraft missiles nobody will will
uh reach us and uh nobody will ever stop
us we're in an underground fema facility
bunker right now ladies and gentlemen we
got spices and we got meals ready to eat
we got chum buckets boys yep that's
right
we're in here we're hunkered in
all right
you next time